i think you're gonna get so much like
interesting data from this approach just
because i'll see you guys so much from
like transcriptatements and then like
different organs as well and yeah i
think there'll be so many like
interesting questions you could ask just
from your day to relay and you're
laughing i think it's true
we're totally like hiring you know more
computational biologists and like doing
more modeling because we have millions
of cells from different species and with
dozens of interventions and like
different biological axes and all this
stuff we i know we have all that data
and i would like love to be able to just
like
spend 100 years going into all of it
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video i had
the great pleasure of speaking with
martin box jensen he was previously a
postdoc at the bach institute for
research on aging but has since gone on
to create guardian biotechnology
a company that have created the first
in-vivo therapeutic screen to improve
drug design for complex diseases of
aging in this discussion we chat further
about how this screen works and what the
company hopes to achieve in terms of
therapeutics as well as martin's recent
project impetus grants for longevity
research and also his general interests
in the aging field
so hi martin thank you very much for
joining me today and welcome to the
cheeky science show
thank you i think this show is great uh
i mean there should be more things out
there that are really
trying to make all of the aging biology
understandable to everyone and
make it clear like what's happening and
what's real and so forth so i'm a big
fan thank you um and also i'm a fan of
your research as well and so i thought
just like to ease ourselves into this
huge topic of aging research and
longevity it'd be interesting to first
kind of hear about what got you
interested into the field and also i
know that you were previously
at the bach institute for research and
aging and you've done some work on
mitochondrion so i was wondering if you
could also tell us a bit about your
contributions
to the field as well
yeah sure um i guess i'm i've been
making contributions in different
uh
areas of aging or at least trying to so
what got me interested was
um honestly like
teenage existential angst about like
what's the meaning of life you know like
what
everything
so i think many people have that phase
maybe so as a i don't know 15 year old
around that um
i was just trying to figure out like
what was the most
meaningful thing that i could spend my
time on and
uh creating time which is now the
tagline for gordian um seemed like a
good one right because whatever else you
value the more time you have um the more
you can experience it
and so that was kind of
the
origin
but of course i didn't know how one went
about doing that and so that's what led
me to become a scientist and go into
training um to do research um first in
back in copenhagen where i'm from uh
first in
managed technology and then um for my
phd i went to the national institute
on aging in baltimore and did most of my
phd there
and part of it in copenhagen at the
center for healthy aging at the
university of copenhagen um and the phd
was more focused on
dna damage and
the diseases that accelerated aging
disorders that happen due to mutations
in dna damage proteins for example
werner syndrome um i didn't work on
hutchinson guilford's progeria which is
the more well-known one
um so that was a phd and then for my
postdoc um so then i had a brief stint
back in denmark where i had to be in the
air force because we still have
mandatory military
um and then for my postdoc at the buck
institute um i wanted to
i guess from my phd it became clear that
like there were many different
mechanisms that were part of the overall
aging and i wanted to not go narrow but
kind of get a sense of the broader
landscape and try to find the levers
that we can use to
advance human health through the
understanding of aging biology
and so i joined the lab of henry jasper
who's now at genentech but then was at
the book
and the lab was mostly focused on stem
cell biology and i did do some work in
those areas
using fruit flies but my main project
was this
phenomenon called the mitochondrial
unfolded protein response basically what
that means in lay terms is that
there's a certain type of stress that
can be sensed by the mitochondria inside
of your cells
and um a couple of other labs had in
worms already shown that if you induce
that stress early in development then
you can extend the lifespan of the
animals uh in their adulthood and that
was kind of interesting and weird like
how do you get these lasting effects and
so that project appealed to me uh for
two reasons one is that it was
mitochondria and mitochondria um
are just really central uh to a lot of
things that we keep finding in the aging
biology field like these
nutrient-sensing pathways and
nad metabolism
and uh so that was one interesting part
of it the other interesting part of it
was that there was apparently something
you could do that then had a lasting
effect on your your health and your
physiology and so if we could figure out
what that was that would be cool um and
so the primary focus of my project there
was
two things one is show that this isn't
just a worm thing so sometimes we find
stuff in one organism that can extend
lifespan but it might be specific to
just that non-human organism and then
it's less interesting to show that it
can happen uh in multiple organisms and
then what hadn't been done at all before
was like what is actually better and i
think that's a
that's an interesting question for the
whole field um i won't go too deep on
that yet but
you know we often find like and then the
mtor pathway and that has been known to
extend lifespan and so therefore this is
not surprising that this thing activates
mtor or inhibits sorry mtor and
therefore livestream but like what's
actually better
right like what is it that made the
organism not die i think that's a
question i'd love to see
i mean it's a tough question but i'd
love to see more people just getting at
that one so i tried to do that um and i
got um
stonewalled by
activation of foxo which is another one
of these
genes that we keep finding um in
different organisms and that's also
one of the few in humans um
sort of out of the genetic studies that
have been done on big populations one of
the top two
genes that is associ where certain
variants of it associated with longer
lifespan so that was the first half of
my post-doc around this mitochondrial
stuff
um and then uh after i had finished that
project i started a new project which is
focused on kind of inter-organ aging and
how inflammation from your intestine or
at least in a fruit fly the intestine
can reach the brain
and then affect the
function or the new degeneration of the
brain
um and then i left
which i'm sure we'll get to cool that's
really interesting so it seems like
you've covered quite a few of the
different i guess like hallmarks of
aging so um from your research has like
so obviously you've got your own kind of
perspective on what aging is and so
how would you kind of describe it i mean
do you think the mitochondria are more
sensual than we currently think or
what are your opinions
no
so so i guess i have a far from unique
and not original but
not
super common view on like what is aging
that has been shaped i think by you know
jumping around and making things live
longer in different ways right like
clearly
it's not all dna damage because you can
also do something else that extends the
lifespan of a mouse um or whatever
organism
and so the way i think about it is
increasingly in terms of
systems biology and how does
so to give an analogy how does a company
or country fail right like there's some
kind of like you start a company which
now i did of course um and then it
becomes a big company and then it can
sometimes like doesn't make it right
like it kind of goes downhill how does
that happen and i think that's
um
actually pretty pertinent to how does
aging happen um
a company
like the human body or like any
multicellular organism is a lot of
different components that are doing
specialized function
and uh there's a system in how all of
that works together and the system can
kind of fall apart and that's what i
think
aging is
in sort of colloquial terms it's a
decline in the
consistency and purity and signal
strength of information flowing through
um
an organism and so
that's why there are many ways that it
can fail and when something fails you
see influences on other mechanisms of
aging right the whole thing goes out of
whack so if we go back to the company
analogy um you know let's say that your
engineering team for making new apple
laptops
are doing a bad job right and then the
laptops suck and then the
sales department's having trouble
because like the product is not good and
then like money comes in and you fire
people and then morale goes down and so
like there's an interconnectedness of
all these things and that's
i mean i'm probably biased but that's
what i feel like i see in um
in the aging field as well there's
countless papers showing that when you
disrupt mitochondrial function then you
can have an effect on telomere length or
then you can have an effect on
inflammation and so forth
so that's kind of my personal view is
that you've got a complex system that
you're trying to to optimize and so you
might need i don't know more ecologists
in
aging guiding the
molecular biologist
nicole that's a really interesting way
of thinking about it and so from your
kind of description would you agree that
aging and then is really hard to study
or like what are the why is aging hard
to study
yeah i think aging is hard to study for
that reason
and probably for other reasons
um
we don't have a perfect definition of
aging right so the best thing we have is
maybe like nine hallmarks or seven
pillars or whatever your preferred
version is and even in those papers
they're like this is a non-exhaustive
list and some of the hallmarks are
different classes of entities than
others right like some of them describe
like intracellular communication is one
of them like that just describes
everything that happens in the body
pretty much right yeah so that's a very
different scope of hallmark compared to
like short telomeres
um
so yeah i don't think we have a an
awesome definition and in my opinion
yeah the definition that we have comes
back to this like complex systems
and yeah that's just a really hard thing
to study especially with the tools that
we have so i think biology has thrived
on using often reduction as tools and
not reductionist in a sort of derogatory
way of like you know not
uh expansive but rather
precise where you can go into a pathway
and you can say okay let's look for
epistasis you know if we remove this
thing and we think this acts through
this and we can like block this then we
can test that hypothesis in a precise
way but
non-linear multi-body interactions uh
pretty hard like we just don't have
great tools uh for studying that and so
i think that's something that would
really benefit the aging field is having
more tools that measure not just the
nodes of the network of aging but also
the edges between them um
in four dimensions right like including
the time dimension um and so then the
other obvious like you know my post talk
i was making flies live longer that's a
terrible assay to be your bread and
butter right because it takes three
months
and the more you succeed in making life
live longer the worse it gets
so i think that's also
a big challenge for the aging field that
the only great metric we have is
lifespan or you know function over time
and that one is slow and so if your
iteration speed is really low then your
rate of progress is going to be lower so
i'm a huge proponent of like biomarkers
but
biomarkers that
are interpretable and mechanistic
yeah so i think i agree i think that it
is very challenging and i also agree
that now we seem to be getting these
improved tools to be able to study
the complex system of aging and so i
think that nicely kind of leads me on to
talking more about guardian
biotechnology and i guess um firstly
would you be able to explain like what
led you to um creating guardian and what
is it how are you trying to tackle and
understand the aging problem
yeah for sure um so
where we laughed last left off in my
life story
i was doing the second project of my
post talk on this
tissue inter-tissue inflammation
signaling um and i actually got a grant
to go start a lab around that
thesis
but
when that happened i kind of looked
ahead i tend to be a a looker a header
uh in life like i kind of take things to
the okay but what really happens
uh you know in the end which is maybe
why my uh original sort of like thinking
about but yeah but then you're just
gonna get old and die so what was the
point of the all in between
i'm not a good uh celebrator in the
moment guy um
so i was looking ahead and thinking
okay
if i study this particular aspect of
aging like i've studied different
aspects of aging before
when am i going to be working
directly towards
um using the knowledge that i gained
over in almost 10 years at the time
to improve human health and the answer
was you know probably not for at least
seven years until you get tenure um and
that's just a long time
so so i felt like i i wouldn't be
maximally vote motivated if i was in
that thing because i would have had this
sort of tickling of like okay but like
what are we gonna do with humans right
and if you're not actually motivated
you're not gonna do
you know your best at it and so it's
kind of a lose-lose um and so eventually
after a lot of uh
considerations i decided that that
wasn't the right thing for me to do and
then kind of had talked to different
people explored different things
eventually decided that
um
you could
in a biotech focused on aspects of
biological aging like there would be the
most aligned with what i wanted of like
a team that's working super hard towards
a shared goal
and then there was a whole process of
finding the right person to do that with
finding the right co-founder and finding
the right idea
that was like a year-long process
at least so
compress all that into i met my
co-founder francisco laporte
whom i eventually started gordian with
and we went through a lot of different
ideas
and the idea that became gordian was
pretty
uh simple in a way it says
aging is important for most of the big
diseases of aging right like there's a
reason they all are correlated and go up
together like this so like
uncontroversial to people in the aging
field
um two what we already addressed i don't
know exactly what aging is and if i
don't then i can't make a perfect sort
of cell culture model that captures all
of it like there's nothing that captures
aging except actual aging because we
don't even know what we're supposed to
model and it seems like you know
different organs playing together is
clearly part of it
and having an immune system and all that
stuff so okay so we should if we want to
curate related diseases we should factor
aging into the search
test system
um the only good system
is actual aging so in vivo
and we don't know what to do so we want
to be able to ask a lot of questions
right
and so if you have to ask a lot of
questions and the answer get answers in
the most relevant environment which is
in vivo now you need a way to do high
throughput testing in vivo
whether you're growing after sort of
aging itself or specific diseases of
aging same deal
um and so then the question was well can
we do that right
and the um
the inspiration for the name was
basically that you know there is this
huge puzzle or not of like all the
complex biology of aging which i had
spent a long time trying to figure out
and you know untangling it just it
wasn't going to get there in the next 50
years so is there a way that we can um
without knowing everything get the right
answer by just asking these many
questions um and so
cut the guardian knob
um and so that's the idea running a lot
of tests inside of living animals and of
course that's uh
tractable without any unique technology
if you just had a lot of animals but
once you start talking about
aged animals that have spontaneously
developed
diseases and frailties that are relevant
for humans and maybe a mouse is not
always the best model that's a whole
topic um i'm not anti-mouse by any means
but certainly for some uh areas they're
unlike humans
there just aren't like those animals
don't exist you can't go out and do
drug discovery the way that let's say
unity by technology or any other classic
biotech company did it
purely in vivo if your test system is
like an old horse that has spontaneously
developed osteoarthritis like we don't
have 10 000
of those
and so the idea that we had
for how to solve this is well what if we
can test many things per animal
what if we can put many different
potential therapies into
the diseased organ
of an old animal and then find a way to
understand what each one
did and that's basically uh that was the
conception idea of the company and
that's what we've spent
uh
the first two years since we started at
the end of 2018 beginning of 2019
building and constructing and then
proving that it works and now we are
scaling that up and applying it to fine
disease uh fine treatments for diseases
cool so um i also previously saw some
work that you presented um
talking about
using your approach to look at
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease so
looking at age-associated diseases and
so i i believe from my understanding the
way it works is that
within one organism you can then give
to one specific tissue so for example
the liver in this case
um different genes such that individual
cells get one gene and then they can
overexpress that gene and so i guess in
a long-winded way i was trying to ask
could you explain exactly more about the
technology itself and what techniques
you're using and how these kind of um
these screening processes actually work
yeah for sure
um and so first off maybe i'll address
um this like diseases aging um what are
we doing there so i think that's
probably familiar uh to your viewers
right now since we don't have a perfect
definition of aging there's no like
going to the fda with a trial that says
like we're targeting aging and we're
going to make people younger and
therefore they're going to not have
diseases in the future and not just the
fda like i think the fda doesn't mind
this but they're just
okay tell us what that means and how
you're going to measure it
which will take a lifetime right so
there's initiatives in that direction
but like it's not there yet um and
likewise you know in terms of how would
you actually
you know measure whether the drug works
get it reimbursed all this stuff so like
the world is not quite there yet where
the promise of
longevity biotechnology um aging biology
to actually prevent diseases from
happening is um straightforward for a
company to kind of go after and so what
everyone is doing currently is
going after specific diseases that um
happen with age and where there's a
well-established path towards like does
your thing do something but then with
treatments that you believe um could
work across multiple diseases of aging
because it's targeting something that's
kind of fundamental and in our case um
also with confidence that it'll actually
work in older people because a lot of
drug discovery for diseases of aging
just uses young animals and it's like
great you'll find a drug that works for
alzheimer's and 25 year olds
unfortunately there are none
and your dark doesn't work so anyway
that's
gordian
at the moment we are going after
specific indications so we have a nash
program a lung fibrosis program and
osteoarthritis program and a heart
failure program
but i am excited about the fact that
nothing in our platform
is
like works only for individual diseases
like the whole thing the whole setup
works exactly the same if the world gets
you know ready to say let's do
preventative medicine broadly um and do
rejuvenation
it works the same so with all that out
of the way
what is it we're actually doing
um
yeah as you said
what we're doing is putting in
a
pool of different gene therapies
targeting different genes that might be
might have the potential to treat a
given disease and then either increasing
or decreasing the expression of that
gene
and this is not particularly even though
we're using gene therapy which is a sort
of new and advanced technology it's not
really that different from
what any other drug company develops
with small molecules and antibodies if
you had an anti like humira which is the
best selling
drug i think of all time it's an
antibody against an inflammatory
protein in the blood and that just helps
disease you're just reducing that
protein and likewise what rapamycin does
which your viewers will know about is it
inhibits uh mtor right emptors target of
rapamycin so that's the same as just
turning mtor down not literally exactly
the same there is actual nuance there
but fundamentally the same thing
and so what we're doing is
creating these libraries of gene
therapies that target for increased or
decreased activity of a whole range of
genes or it could be combinations of
genes
and then taking
taking that library and putting it into
an animal and because it's so this is
why we're using gene therapy um what
we're delivering is actually a little
virus that has been gutted of its normal
viral um
content and instead it contains this dna
that'll increase the or let's say
decrease the expression of mtor uh
components um and it has exactly one
payload like one uh piece of dna inside
of it and it's gonna go in through the
bloodstream get to the liver in this
example and then
reach one hepatocyte in the liver one of
the cells in the liver and deliver its
payload there
and then that's it and so
if we use
a low amount of virus so that
the most of the cells in the liver don't
actually receive any payload just a very
small percentage of them get anything
then what you end up with is still a
diseased liver so this whole environment
with immune cells infiltrating and
cell cell communication and so forth
that's relatively unperturbed but
individual cells within that liver let's
say a million cells within that liver
out of the 100 million that are in a
mouse liver
have received some sort of biological
push
by either up or down regulating a
certain gene and
so this is where the technology comes in
we have these dna barcodes uh in the
gene therapy payloads um
and so what you end up with is in each
of these cells some biology will change
right like you'll reduce mtor activity
and then that will change the
hepatocytes biological cell state
um and you have
millions of these independent cellular
experiments happening throughout the
liver and then we have a way of um
pulling out those cells that had
received a therapy and then
using what's called single cell
transcriptomics we can
read the state of those cells we can
read the activity of every gene
in that cell
and basically see you know what is it
doing and does it look more like a
disease cell which we know it started
out as or more like a healthy cell and
we can compare it to
cells in that same tissue where we
didn't do anything where we delivered a
payload that does nothing
and then we can ask along many different
sort of
biological activity axes did anything
change um and so that gives us what's
called a phenotypic readout for have you
improved the state of the disease
and so that's the basic the core
platform technology platform uh within
gordian is this ability to put
in a controlled or semi-controlled way
many different things into a sick organ
have independent cellular experiments
happen within that organ and then pull
out and actually interpret what happened
in each case rather than just what
happened on average
oh no that's really well explained um so
i think yeah i understand the concept
that even within just one organ
different cells have different genetic
slight changes whether it's as you say
increasing the expression of a gene or
decreasing the expression
and so
this is an individual cell within the
organ and then you can extract these
individual cells and you sequence them
to look at the changes um of expression
and then you from that alone you can
understand if it's got a more of a
healthy state or a disease state
yeah that's exactly right cool so i
think
so the example that um we've already
spoken about is in the liver but
like what what kind of like other um
diseases you've mentioned osteoarthritis
and so how does it work in terms of
delivering this
these different genetic changes these
gene therapies to different tissues is
that something that's quite easy or is
that quite challenging
um
it's not totally trivial but
basically we are
um
following in the wake of people who have
pioneered gene therapy um delivery to
different tissues although in the u.s
the first uh gene therapy approval um
was luxterna and it was approved in 2017
for a genetic disease uh causing
blindness
um so
um katherine high and others like push
that forward
and at this point there are
hundreds of trials doing gene therapy in
humans
in a range of different organs liver
muscle heart
eye brain
lung
cartilage uh probably some that i'm
forgetting um where there's this whole
field that's like just like blowing up
the gene therapy field is very hot and
there's a lot of activity and there's a
bunch of problems and people are
addressing those problems and what we're
doing is just relying on the work done
by all of those people to
first find
the right way to do gene delivery in
just animal models which is what we're
doing first of course
and where the bar is lower than doing it
actually in a clinic
where safety is an even bigger concern
and also the doses are higher and so
forth um
and yeah we're just
fortunate that they're paving the way
for us and you know we're doing some
development and optimization stuff at
gordian our platform can be used for
many things including optimizing gene
therapies
but they are we're focused on the areas
where things where paths are being
not only paths are being trod but like
the roads are getting paved by other
companies so i let other people take
that risk um
so in the liver you know like that's
that's done like we we deliver gene
therapies to deliver we've done that in
many humans there are still concerns
about
toxicity at really high doses and
manufacturing and so forth but those are
what the rest of the field is focused on
for curing
primarily genetic diseases so where they
know exactly the gene to put in right
and then the future of gene therapy is
going to be okay this technology is
really amazing it can do all these
things they can do targeted things you
don't have you know off
effects on some other tissue and then
you have all these side effects um
but
for many diseases the problem is we
don't know what we actually want to do
and so that's what we're figuring out
and then
you know coming up behind all the
delivery methods development that's
already happening
cool and so once you've done this screen
and you've like identified certain genes
that look quite promising in terms of
their transcriptome their sequencing
readouts what's the kind of next step i
mean do you then just have that one gene
and you do it in one mouse alone or do
you like combine multiple genes together
that you think might
um work well together be like
synergistic is that the kind of idea
yeah it all depends on the science so i
think both of the things you said are
definitely on the radar um
for sure we have to like our screen is a
screen and screens will always have
false positives um rs too um so you do
want to follow up and validate and you
can do that by putting all the stuff
into a single mouse now keep in mind
you're
you're still living in in normal biology
land where everything happens in mice
but you know for our osteoarthritis
program we're already in horses our
heart program is in pigs and so forth so
it might not be a mouse but
um
which is like really you sort of like
wrap your head around that um
so doing that sort of saturating high
dose single target that's a very
important follow-up experiment it's also
really important to um
get as much confidence that what you're
doing is relevant in humans as possible
right because you don't want to cure
mice ultimately or even
well
there's probably there's actually a
decent business in curing horse
osteoarthritis but
we do want to cure humans also and so
there's different things you can do
there i mean in our in our um
bioinformatics there's a lot of
bioinformatics and sort of uh fancy data
science that happens here obviously um
and we are getting within the company
and and externally um
human samples as well so when we do
analyze the results of the screen we are
looking for like is this shift that
happened something that is
preserved in or conserved in human
diseases and so forth um but you can
also do that in the validation stage
right so you can go into models let's
say for for osteoarthritis
there's something called an explant
model where you can take out some of the
cartilage of the knee typically happens
when people are having knee replacement
surgery because nobody has care
arthritis yet
and then you take some of that and then
you can you can do additional
experiments there just to confirm that
your stuff also happens in uh it works
in in human context um but yeah the
combination part of it is really
interesting because i think a lot of
these age-related diseases they are just
complex and they have different types of
biology going on
and so being able to map that out like
what i'm really excited about what we
can do is we can do these huge screens
so normal
development
you usually have a target hypothesis so
let's say a beta 42 is the right target
for alzheimer's and you find stuff that
hits that and then you do animal models
that test that hypothesis
um
and if your hypothesis is wrong then it
doesn't ultimately doesn't work right
um
and you you focus on like pushing the
drug forward so of course we need to
push drugs forward but before we get
there we can get indivo like relevant
model data across many many many like
hundreds thousands of genetic targets
and then we can look at that whole
landscape and say which way do we want
to go right so we get this aerial view
of the entire
like downstream
uh
pre-clinical and clinical development
and we can then decide like what makes
the most sense maybe it's a combination
therapy
maybe this thing is a gene therapy maybe
um there's a different modality maybe
there's a drug already on the market
that we actually discover will work for
some other indication
so i think that's really the power of
our platform is to give us that high
level view and then figure out what are
the additional tests that we want to do
to determine that this is really
going to be solid in the clinical trials
which is of course the part where it
gets
really really expensive
you know hundreds of times as expensive
as uh running our screen
yeah for sure um and so well actually
having said that um the single cell
sequencing i guess has somewhat cost as
well and it's actually interested in
that because obviously one of the
reasons why there's a lot of excitement
around single cell um rna sequencing
approaches
is the fact that you can use it to see
like her fragility within like an organ
for example or like a population of
cells and so there's like natural
heterogeneity um within the different
organs that you're looking at and so
because your approach is mainly like
single-celled transcriptomics does that
influence the data like the background
noise in the sample
and then from that are there like
alternative ways in which you could also
try and get like an assay to see how
effective a different gene is so like
whether it's imaging or what kind of
like other tools do you think can be
used
yeah so
there is definitely heterogeneity and
the good news is that we have um
we have visual on that right like we can
see it in our data and so we can always
just choose to sequence more cells
which is moderately expensive so as you
pointed out like single cell sequencing
is not as cheap as like taking photos of
cells but taking photos of cells um
is not as high throughput and it doesn't
work as well in vivo right so
um so i think there's kind of there's
two
two answers that i want to give so one
is back to what we were saying before
this screen is to find hypotheses which
we then go and back up right so like
there there are lots of other data
modalities both but still based on
single cell but looking at chromatin
accessibility or adding a spatial
element with spatial transcriptomics
that we can follow up on the interesting
hits with and then we go into the whole
animal physiology
with those hits and then we test you
know single thing and one animal
measure whatever blood cholesterol
inflammatory cytokines histology all the
usual assays that everyone would do so
like the follow-up for us definitely
involves uh different modalities
and
that feeds back into our uh transcriptic
analysis so the cool thing about using
the single cell transcript well there's
several things other than the fact that
it gives a single cell readout which we
like fundamentally need otherwise you
can't do this right
um
is that
the
so to speak language that it's in
is gene expression
and the
uh
interventions that we put in that are
gene therapies they exist in the same
language there's no translation that
happens
and so
if you have a traditional uh molecule
and you got some phenotype that says
this is better often the problem is in a
small molecule screen you don't actually
know what happened like you didn't know
what you did um so you have to figure
that out so it slows down whereas ours
is much more like the covet vaccine like
sequence the virus you know what you
want to target design nucleotides that
target that and then you can like go go
straight uh back there
and we can also add other so when we add
other modalities to our transcriptomic
data um we can and we do this very
actively um we can find the
transcriptomic signatures that represent
certain physiological outcomes let's say
fibrosis and like different severities
of fibrosis so we kind of take this full
transcriptome
and
create modules that predict certain
other stuff based on the other data
that we've generated so in addition to
just sort of generating that data to
validate what we're doing it also feeds
back into what we can actually interpret
from the transcriptome
and especially once you add the
perturbations to it right because like
biology is really hard to understand as
a static snapshot you don't want to have
a hypothesis and then like put a thing
in the test you're about to see if what
you thought happened
uh would happen
so
yeah that's the main thing and then in
terms of the
cellular heterogeneity that's definitely
you see that in these diseases and we
can see that in the transcription and
there's inter-animal um heterogeneity
right so um and into patient right like
different patients will have different
outcomes some people who have fatty
liver develop nash um
where they have inflammation and
fibrosis and some just don't they just
have fatty liver um
and we see that in in the mice as well
and we use that because
so this is a part that actually gets
really you know you get a freebie
benefit of doing the pooled in vivo
screening instead of
using individual animals so normally you
take let's say 10 animals in this group
and then 10 animals in this group and
you'd give them one treatment and the
different treatment or control treatment
and then you say what changed the
problem is that the animal's all
different and so
um
if the animals in this group
were just intrinsically different in
some way now you've got like a problem
that like this
you know plus the treatment is not this
it's like different animals plus the
effect of the treatment and you can't
disentangle them and of course people
are aware of this and they try to
normalize like you look at all the
weights of the animals or you certainly
have the same sex and the same age and
so forth but still there are things we
don't know about
and so when you do the pool then we will
screening you have uh controls in each
animal so we can still do 10 animals and
just split our screen over more animals
even though i often say you know put
everything into a single animal we don't
have to use just one single animal you
can use different animals with different
biological phenotypes
and then we have controls in each one
and so you get the effect vector of the
potential therapy you put in and you say
what
is the effect of this relative to doing
nothing in that same animal and then you
get that across the different
backgrounds so we actually can utilize
the biological variability of these
diseases
to understand um when like does this
intervention always do something or is
it only if you have a certain starting
state are there some of these drugs that
might be good for preventing progression
to nash but not for like reverting nash
which gets super valuable once you start
thinking about your clinical trial and
like what are the patient segments that
you think it would be valuable to go
after
yeah cool that's really well explained
and so i guess
at the moment you spoken about different
age stages age-associated diseases but
how would you if like the fda is now
like yes we can
study aging um and so what how would you
adapt to look at aging itself
um and we spoke earlier about how it's
complex and intercellular um how would
you maybe adapt your current approach to
look at maybe multiple organs at the
same time is that even like possible
yeah so this this gets to
so i think guardian is a good idea
because i think you want to be in vivo
and aced animals if you want to cure
these ideas for these diseases right so
like that's the starting point the other
thing i think is that for aging
like if we really want to do something
about aging and have a beneficial impact
on health through aging
um
i think i don't know how many people
think there's a silver bullet kind of
like one thing that will just do
everything we need
um probably many people will say no it
was probably not a silver bullet even
though there's exciting things you know
partial programming whatever um that
might look like that um
but
our system for finding things where like
you need to do this in this organ and
then this in this organ or cell type and
they're like different things
is pretty limited like we don't have
a lot of work going on that would even
get at that because almost every
intervention we put in it's in the form
of a drug or a genetic knockout or
something that affects the whole
organism
and so
if we do need to do this sort of modular
fine-tuning organ and cell type specific
push
in an aging direction um i think gordian
is kind of a backstop for the whole
field like if that's really what we need
then we're developing technology that
allows us to figure that out
um to a certain extent like we're still
limited how much we can study non-linear
interactions between different organs
like the way our platform is set up
right now it's it's not good at
figuring out that like if you do
something in this organ then this is
what happens in this other organ for
technical reasons we can skip for now
right so so it's it's only a start um
but at least it is a start of trying to
map out
even the things that we know are can be
sort of beneficial for aging like igf-1
signaling or something like that right
like it's
in the brain you want maybe less of it
and then in like your bone marrow stem
cells you want more of it as you age and
like we've seen already different
examples of like this pathway is like an
aging pathway but there are other
instances where it's like not beneficial
right um
and
personally i suspect that the reason we
keep finding these nutrient sensing
pathways is because those are the ones
that work
like net positive but that there are
plenty of examples of like you can make
this tissue better with this small nudge
but then it makes something else worse
and so you don't see anything in the
lifespan right
and that's something that we can map out
um with our technology because we're
finding cell type specific like what
happens when you do a certain push and
when we create these disease maps like i
said where we can see you know this is
what all these perturbations do to all
these specific biological
axes
in this disease and in this disease and
this disease if we think that you know
lung fibrosis and liver fibrosis has a
shared etiology in aging something that
happens
um then we'll see that and we'll have
biological features that we create in
our sort of transcriptomic space
um
that correspond to you know what have
you the hallmarks telomeres senescence
all these factors right and if the
geoscience hypothesis is correct then
we'll start to see
um that some of these diseases have a
big role being played by mitochondria or
vicinism cells and we can see where that
overlaps and that lets us not only um
you know we can do the same strategy
that another aging longevity company
would do which is like i
i take this drug i'm starting an
osteoarthritis trial but i think that
it'll also work in this other indication
yes that
plus
we've mapped out whether it's going to
work in that other indication because
we've done a big screen right and we've
identified these modules that represent
shared things and so we start with them
not perfect information but like an
informed path towards like what
what over sort of overlapping but
complementary set of nudges do you need
across the body in order to get to an
overall healthier state and maybe much
healthier
cool i think you're going to get so much
like interesting data from this approach
just because also you get so much from
like transcriptatements and then like
different organs as well and yeah i
think there'll be so many like
interesting questions you could ask just
from your day to relay and you're
laughing i think it's true no like if
we're like
we're totally like hiring you know more
computational biologists and like doing
more modeling because we have millions
of cells from different species and with
dozens of interventions and like
different biological axes and all this
stuff we i know we have all that data
and i would like love to be able to just
like
spend 100 years going into all of
earlier this year i got my first like
rna sequencing data set myself for part
of my like phd project and literally um
i still haven't i mean i still need like
i could spend the rest of my life
probably looking at it i mean why don't
i almost but yeah i completely
understand
um but going on from that um
you obviously get all this data and
information and you can make predictions
about what genes are going to be good to
activate or inhibit for different
diseases and so going from that to then
like the clinical trials are we talking
supplements or different molecules that
inhibits the the
the proteins encoded by the genes or are
you thinking more gene therapy as the
ultimate therapeutic outcome
it depends um and so we are
not supplements like we're playing we're
going the fda route um
but it could be gene therapies it could
be other biologics or it could be small
molecules
once again that's really guided by once
we have mapped out the landscape we can
see the best path and so for some organs
where
let's say we find something for
osteoarthritis which is like an isolated
tissue so a small volume
and a gene therapy would make sense
because the actual hit that we got is
increased activity of a transcription
factor which is not something that any
you know like the
estimated i'm not sure how accurate
these estimates are but you know like
rough estimated how much of the
genome can we target with small
molecules it's on the order of 10
of the genome and then when you add
biologics you get another 10 but 80 of
it is like we just don't know how to do
this thing we generally don't know how
to activate a transcription factor or
mediate a protein protein interaction
um
we're better at inhibiting things than
activating things and so forth right so
it's very possible that what we'll find
in our screen is that the strongest
biological path towards reversal of this
disease is through something that
doesn't make sense as a small molecule
it wouldn't really be possible
and so that would be obnox towards gene
therapy
also
one of the challenges for gene therapy
in the clinic right now is can you make
enough virus and so you'd much rather
use gene therapy for something like the
eye
where you know you only need a small
dose uh of virus um knee joints would
also work uh for that
um
conversely you know it could be that you
find something where a target where like
there's already a well-characterized
antibody or a small molecule that has
passed your phase one trial already and
then for sure you'd want to in-license
that to cut years off of your clinical
path so
we are
somewhat agnostic i think it's
long term i'm very bullish on gene
therapy because you can do these
targeted perturbations um that uh won't
will
if you need a cocktail of things to like
really get at aging um then
it would be best if each thing had a
more sort of targeted and organ specific
effect right um so for aging in general
i'm very bullish on gene therapy long
term
and in the short term you know we'll
look at those paths and we'll take the
one that makes the most sense if it's
gene therapies probably gordian will do
more of the heavy lifting if it's a
small molecule maybe we'll partner with
um some big pharma company um who has a
stronger med cam department or will in
license something so
yeah it's agnostic it's not uh
it's not it depends on what makes the
most sense once you've seen the big
picture
yeah that's also really exciting um so
obviously you do a lot of research um
at scorpion and at the same time or more
recently you've now um co-founded maybe
i'm incorrect there um impetus grants
for longevity research so you're now
also
involved in helping
other researchers who are also studying
aging to get funding for their research
and so i was just wondering if you could
talk about a bit more about it and how
that's initiated and yeah what are your
goals for that yeah yeah yeah i don't
know if uh i guess co-founded makes it
make sense um
i mean
i just want the field to move forward as
fast as possible towards improving human
health that's kind of like the
overarching ambition and the prime
directive um
and so the longevity impetus grants
started um
sort of serendipitously
where i was at an event and i was
hearing a presentation on the covet 19
fast grants
which
happened as a response to
the
immediate impact
of cover 19 obviously right and then the
um
the inconsistency between like the need
to
apply science to this problem because
obviously like the solution was in
science as we've now seen
and the typical timelines of like
scientific funding which in the u.s
through the nih
the
sort of the cycle
is that you apply and then it'll take
four
more months before it gets discussed
and then you'll get a score and then
like the money is typically in hand
like a year later
um and so
you don't want to wait a year to do
covert research this makes perfect sense
and so
tyler cowan and patrick collison started
this thing called code 19 fast grants
where
they had experts
review proposals to work on covet um and
they after only a couple of weeks you
could get funding to do something and i
saw a presentation of um patrick was
presenting this
um
and just looking at like what happened
you know and it's i don't know it's
impossible to measure scientific impact
but you know in terms of all the
standard metrics of like people
published findings
you know clinical trials were started
and so forth um
it seemed to work really well and like
not that differently so
that made me think okay we should try
doing this for longevity for different
reasons one is that longevity is um
just as
urgent as covet right and this is a
little bit maybe controversial statement
but like
literally a hundred thousand people are
dying a day from age-related diseases if
you can find some way to really like
alleviate a wide range of age-related
diseases through
applying aging biology that has a huge
impact on human health around the world
and so i feel that you know this is uh
super urgent
there's all kinds of discussions you can
go into in terms of the demographics and
climate change and all these reasons why
we need to fix that but basically we do
or healthcare won't work
and
the aging field is
still underfunded at the basic research
level like in the us the national
institute on aging has one of the
smaller budgets smaller than many of the
individual diseases that have aging as
the number one risk factor
like cancer
has 10 times the budget
and half of that budget is earmarked for
alzheimer's specific research so more
diseases um and then a lot of it is
sociology and different things so like
the actual nih funding that goes out for
like figure out what aging is and how we
can like
uh use that biology to prevent disease
is around 350 million a year
um
which is you know in my opinion like
poor cost benefit analysis and
it's complicated right it's not that if
if everyone was convinced that this
would uh had the potential that i think
it does to improve human health and i
don't think that would be the case and
there's a lot of communication that
needs to happen and so forth but
certainly there's plenty of money that
could go into the basic research part
especially because right now there is a
lot of money going into the sort of
startup uh company formation part of it
and so i wanted more money for that
and i wanted
to take the opportunity to
[Music]
fund
some of the questions
see if we could fund some of the
projects that would address some of the
questions that
kind of really would push the field
forward towards human impact again so
um
some of this might be that
more high-risk research so we give
several examples of projects that are
now super impactful for the field like
parabiosis um
from
arena convoy and tomatoes lab 2005 um
she had a postdoc fellowship but there's
no nih funding for like these parabolas
experiments
um the epigenetic clocks that you're
very well familiar with right like
corvath just like did all of that
himself
no funding for that um
partial reprogramming we'll see how that
story plays out but that work was
basically funded by a couple of private
foundations and some spanish funding so
like there are these big deal things
that
um
never got nih funding and so can we
complement the funding that the nih is
doing with
you know more risky bets that like maybe
75 chance this doesn't work and 25
chance it's like a new session at the
conference uh you know in a couple of
years um
and a whole new field
um
and also
the type of
i don't know like maybe unsexy work that
like
like we should do some clinical trials
on rapamycin like i like matt gaberline
a lot um he's doing the dog aging
project and like testing repromising in
animals like we have these drugs that
are making mice live 30 longer
and
there's not like a huge carnival of like
celebration going on and there's not a
ton of human trials going on and it's
like kind of wild so so simple ideas
like
oh if this thing might work let's test
it in a bunch of pets
or we have these epigenetic clocks and
we don't know if they're
correlation or causation and we don't
know what they're measuring let's find
out so
kind of this kind of infrastructure
stuff biomarkers i think is usually
important
so we wanted to push funding for those
kinds of things get more funding in
general
take the concept of like fast grant to n
equals two and see like oh could you
just
like how will this go terribly wrong and
if it doesn't then should we think about
how we're how we're doing funding
um
and so
i um
i managed to convince um our initial
donor is um juan bennet um who is a
an entrepreneur in crypto space he
started protocol labs um to put in the
first several million
and then um relied very heavily on uh
the longevity apprentices so that's
actually a third hat that i wear
which is a mentoring program for people
who want to
uh make an impact on aging biology but
either come from
either they come from like biology but
they don't know how do we
how do i
um
put together a big initiative how do you
make something happen something like
instance grants but also something like
juvenile and various other projects that
are happening like how do you get pull
all those things together or they're
coming from maybe it's like an
entrepreneur or something and they like
i understand how to do stuff but i don't
know what to do in aging biology i want
to develop good taste in like am i
solving an actual real problem not a
fake problem
um so that was a program that had
started um earlier
uh this year wow it's this year it all
happened this year
that's kind of crazy um so yeah we
started i started even thinking about
interest grants in june this year and
at this point we've awarded
uh
10 or 12 million and kind of going up
um
by the day um i think by the
end of the year we'll have awarded 25
million dollars worth of brands or
something like that
um and so so these apprentices they have
really been doing you know like all of
this operational work
of
finding reviewers i knew a lot of people
but like finding more reviewers for
different areas building
a ui for the review so i've been a
reviewer
and
i had a lot of opinions about how this
needed to work like if we're gonna if
i'm gonna review hundreds of grants
like i want to see the grant full here
and i want my like review
um input to be right next to it on the
same page i don't want to click a link
right and like go to a different thing
it needs to be all smooth and set up and
so forth and so they've designed all
those things and handle the
correspondence with the universities and
all of this stuff
and um
so they that program had just started in
may like a month earlier and then
basically between june and september we
pulled together a bunch of reviewers who
are people that i trust they're all
anonymous
but people that i trust to have both
knowledgeable about aging not super
biased for like this is the only thing
that's worth doing
and sort of progress minded um and
experts in different technical areas we
did fundraising where as i mentioned we
got around 27 million total committed
from
multiple people so juan
james fickle put in a bunch of money
dead mccaleb metallic buterin carl
flager and fred ursum
and
those are the public and then there's
anonymous donations also
and
then just tweeted out hey guys we have
money send ideas
and hundreds of people send ideas
and it was pretty hectic to review
everything we set a deadline of three
weeks
but it worked mostly there were a few
that fell through the cracks for various
reasons um but yeah we a lot of people
got
um
grants within a month of like writing
spending a day or something putting
together a proposal for a lot of
projects that i think are like really
yeah very clearly this should happen
like please do this
so so there's been a ride
now i can imagine um but that sounds
good really exciting um and so how are
those different like projects are there
any that seem like most exciting or any
that you're quite interested in
um yes but uh i signed an nda to like
look at all these things not to disclose
them so
maybe i'll talk a little bit about
themes
um
i think there were
there were a few projects that are like
um
that i really liked that were around
what i call mechanistic biomarkers like
biomarkers that we could potentially use
in trials and that
aren't black box but they tell us
something specific about the biology
that's happening so they're measuring
specific things like autophagy or
information
personally i think that's going to be
hugely important
next year i'm going to be thinking more
about biomarkers
as well
so those are cool i mean some of them
were just like
especially some of the ones around like
weird model organisms were just crazy
like um i learned a lot of things about
interesting
things
um
and then um
yeah yeah i think that's i think that's
what i'll say so i'm hoping that there's
gonna be lots of exciting announcements
uh sort of over the next several years
right i mean some of this work will take
a long time to do but i'm already
excited by you know if you go on twitter
um there's lots of people posting
uh not only like i got a grant this is
awesome but also like i got a grant and
this was the best like grant experience
i've ever had in terms of like the
smoothness or um some of our reviewers
also say that so i guess all my
nitpicking worked out
or like i'm a grad student and i got a
grant because mostly you can't apply for
an nih grant um as a grad student right
so like our reviews are blinded to who
they came from in the assessment of like
does this have um
does it have the potential for a big
impact and so that ended up giving
grants to various people who were like
not at famous universities and grad
students and people who were coming from
like outside the aging field per se
uh to come and do some really
interesting things um so that's that's
one thing that i'm already really
excited about is that
uh
yeah people get to do the stuff that
they
like have a
an urge to like this is the really quick
the question i really want to answer
right and then if you can answer that
like
then that's great that's how science
should work
awesome and that's really good to hear
that yeah people that doesn't matter
where they're from or what stage of
their career they're able to get this
funding and so is it i mean i think is
there certain times can people apply at
the moment or will it be like reopening
later
so
for now it's closed we closed at the
beginning of uh november um
and
um we're running through all of the
grants that we received and um then
we'll see what the situation is with um
funding if there's funds left over after
everything we've received now i think
most likely we will open up again in
january or february
probably with some targeted by calls for
proposals around specific topics or
questions something like that
and then after that um we'll see i mean
i would love for this program to uh
continue
uh but
um i would also love not to be running
it because
guardian so it was kind of like
opportunistically this seemed like such
a
good opportunity to to do a proof of
concept um for the aging field and push
things forward um so i'm
talking to some people and if anyone uh
listening to this is like yes i would
love to run the impetus uh grants
program and here's why i'm going to be
amazing at like going out and raising
funding for next year's round or springs
round or whatever um and managing the
whole thing then get in touch i guess
and hopefully we can we can keep it
alive
yeah hopefully um so speaking more
generally about just aging are there any
particular areas that you're most
excited about um or you think's got a
lot of potential for the future or like
more and for that like where do you see
the field going in general over like the
next 10 or so years
um
yeah i mean i have to say biomarkers
like it doesn't matter if you're excited
about semester cells or partial
programming or whatever
like if the way that we're going to go
about applying aging biology to
human health is to
have a new pathway that could let us
target like specific you know cancers or
specific age-related diseases
that's just not optimal efficiency and
transitioning to so i mean the vision i
have and this is something i'll
probably communicate much more about
next year
is that um
we should have
mechanistic biomarkers of aging like
interpretable biomarkers for different
aspects of aging so i have a whole panel
of them
and those should be measured
in every clinical trial that happens in
the u.s and
anywhere um
right in in a centralized way so that we
kind of weaponize
every drug trial
um to measure does this have an effect
on these pathways of aging that we can
then demonstrate or in some cases
already have demonstrated
are important for the development of
certain diseases right because this way
you do kind of a mapping many potential
drugs to a few pathways to many
different diseases and if you know these
links and if you then turn every trial
that's tested you just measure these few
things
now you are just totally you know in a
synergistic way supercharging uh the
number of tests we do and i think this
is you know like we we in our field
we'll talk about longevity drugs or
aging drugs or whatever it is right
killing senescent cells now it's aging
it's not something else right but
i mean the things we have that maybe
work or the best contenders we have
rapamycin
is it an aging drug i guess maybe now
we've co-opted it but it's an immuno
modulatory drug right like there's a
transplant drug that foramen is a
diabetes drug so it's not like there's
some
physically or chemically special thing
that makes something an eating drug
and so to really realize the the power
of this field to completely change
healthcare my vision is this
you know whether it's a new branch of
government or some institute that is um
developing mechanistic biomarkers
showing the links to
different age-related diseases and then
um
measuring the effect of every compound
on those biomarkers it's kind of like
a scaled-up version of gordium right
like we're accordion we're taking all of
the different perturbations
measuring their effect on a reduced you
know dimensionality set of
transcriptomic modules and then we know
which modules map to which diseases you
do that whole thing but at the clinical
trial scale so that's the thing i'm
personally most excited that's the way
that i would want to see things going
whether or not that specific project you
know happens in the next five years
we need biomarkers right like there's no
way we can utilize the power of the
aging fields if the output is like
lifespan or something like that
yeah i'd say i guess somewhat on from
that um do you have any like advice for
anyone wanting to get into the field or
like advice more generally about um
other people wanting to do um improve
their health or like um yeah what would
you
advise me
yeah well improve your health i mean you
probably already know
um right
just do the obvious stuff of like eat
vegetables don't eat sugar exercise more
um
and then yeah i mean if you're super
serious about this i tend to say like go
and do something in the aging field
um like it's not that big of a field
it's thousands of people um
and
people more people doing the right
things
um can have an impact right i mean look
at the impetus grants right i helped
kickstart things the donors were
invaluable but the donors are excited
about doing things in the aging field
right and then a small team of motivated
people the longevity of princesses like
were able to make that happen like it
would not have happened if those people
hadn't been like committed to spending
time on doing right things in the aging
field um of course you have to find the
right things to spend time on and that's
why the apprenticeship started was to
give people good taste in aging biology
as well as this operational um
operational capability or training if
you will
and there's different you know there's
different ways that you can learn about
that i think
the key things are
yeah well so i'll do a little bit of
self-promotion which is like go to my
pin tweet on twitter and you can put the
link or something
where i try to talk about a bunch of
this stuff of like what's
how are you going to get misled when you
first enter the aging field um and then
as part of that there's a a link to a
video which you can also find on
martinborgjensen.com there's a link to
that um
it's like a three-hour whole thing where
i spend more time on this of like what
are the bottlenecks what are the places
people should go so
those resources already exist um but try
to find
try to find someone to trust like try to
find some
like you don't need to go get a biology
phd if you have a friend who has a aging
biology phd right and like whom you can
actually trust and then try to think
about things from a
i would say from a perspective and this
is actually apprenticeship like from a
perspective of like where's the end goal
and what are the blocks and like how are
we going to get there but think through
that whole process or at least try to
think this super hard right and like
nobody has the perfect answers
um but try to think about
those things and and then spend your
time on
like what is it that most needs to be
done
and especially if you're willing to do
uncool stuff like there's a lot of stuff
that needs to get done we need a lot
more aids animals to do our studies like
not just gordian but like the whole
field if what i said before like if
every you know number one risk factor
for cancer is aging for most cancers
like a few like testicular is not true
so
all cancer trials should happen in old
animals like oh sorry not trials
pre-clinical research
and that's not happening um and it's not
happening because people aren't thinking
that much about aging maybe but it's
also not happening because there aren't
that many animals right like you
couldn't do that so somebody needs to
like here's a project that i'm also kind
of the apprentices might work on like go
and really map out what are the ideal
model organisms to model different
aspects of human aging
and then with that map we'll know what
are
what organisms do we need to start
massive cohorts of animals aging now if
we want to like run some experiments on
them in five years totally unsexy nobody
wants to do that right like everyone
wants to find a new drive
right um
lobbying efforts you know like biomarker
infrastructure like the biobanks in
europe are great um and everyone always
goes to like uk biobanks to do anything
even from the us because it's great like
could we make not shitty
banks in the u.s right doing things like
that there are lots of things that you
can do if you're like sincerely
motivated um to do something and people
are welcome to like send me an email i'm
kind of like
i guess
adjacent to a lot of different efforts
that are happening and so if people are
like here's what i want to do
um
[Music]
like what who should i talk to who can
help me or like who
yeah how should i make a contribution to
the field i
until i get totally bombarded um i'm
very happy to answer those because i
want people to like
yeah to be able to
uh
fulfill their desire to like
add purpose and like
make a big difference in what they think
is most important
good answer and i was just about to ask
you where is the best place for people
to contact you obviously i can put your
links in the description
yeah um there's a website like my full
name martinportjensen.com
um
twitter is good martin b jensen you can
put all those links in so um yeah
probably twitter is maybe best if you're
on twitter or email
hello.martinborjensen.com
gmail.com
will work as well
and then for
yeah and then just describe what's going
on there's different
paths like the apprenticeship and or
just like
i want to do stuff
which labs should i join
some of the ones that just got impetus
grants a lot of them now they're like
hey we got money we need postdocs
student
awesome well i think that's a really
great way to end it's been an absolute
pleasure to talk with you and hear about
what you're doing at guardian but also
beyond just helping the aging field in
general it's just been yeah great to
kind of pick your brain and learn about
i guess the forefront of the research
thanks so much yeah this has been really
fun enjoyed it that's good to hear
so i hope you've learned something in
this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you